[Musique]
vous avez étudié pendant quatre ans
l'anglais à l'école alors je vais poser
une question voyez do you think about
the king of language in france en mai
prochain
non pas tellement vous avez appris
l'anglais pendant 8 à dire je vais faire
un petit test avec vous j'ai le
vocabulaire on déjoue poser deux mots au
hasard comment dit-on observé en anglais
to look to watch et comme on dit ont
lancé un clin d'oeil est incapable de
dire d'humour pâtisser way to go to the
mérignac et reporte tout sous marine a
rapporté 6 3
nous ici e
alors je vais vous poser en français
qu'est ce que vous pensez de
l'enseignement des langues étrangères en
france c'est pas tellement pour moi je
trouve que c'est pas c'est pas bien ça
ne s'est même pas tellement bien simple
fatalement apprendre l'anglais surtout
l'anglais je crois parce que c'est la
langue principale quand même monsieur
aux cards
[Musique]
moi je pense que on apprend mieux en
allant dans un pays
une semaine
semaine que en apprenant à l'école après
quatre années d'études vous êtes
incapable de parler aussi bien sur un
tout petit peu on se dit oui un peu mais
will see the direction on
[Musique]
hand suite on
oh
non
après sept ans d'études d'anglais au
lycée de bordeaux où est ce que vous
pouvez répondre à cette question what do
you think about teaching of language in
france au racing de way of teaching in
french special in bordeaux 19h
lewis books and we're not speak in love
c'est que l'enseignement mais pas très
bon parce qu'on apprend sur les livres
on ne parle pas suffisamment anouilh
aussi ceux d'ericsson cap ferret
bouteille à cap ferret un oubli ou le
rail
[Musique]